ich flüchte josef liefers auf jeden fall
bei einem verbot ist ein schwaches
zeichen für die demokratie aber ich
glaube dass man die vorkommnisse in
berlin ein bisschen auch unter folgendem
aspekt betrachten sollte das was da
geschehen ist es eigentlich ein signal
dafür ein symptom das unsere
gesellschaft eine an einer krankheit
leidet und diese pandemie die uns alle
sehr fordert erzeugt sehr viel auch an
diesem punkt zustimmung für jan josef
liefers vieler menschen stehen am rand
ihrer existenz perspektive und sehen
gefahren auf sich zukommen die dazu
führen dass sie sich irgendwann mal aus
der mitte weg bewegen und diese
empfindsamkeit die im augenblick ihre
nervosität nicht da ist ist ein
fantastischer nährboden solche leute
anzusprechen und zu radikalisieren
ja das ist alles noch gar nicht
kontrolliert aber das sieht man ja an
diesen vielen schichten artikulation ja
aber da deutet sich eigentlich eine
größere bewegung an und darauf müsste
man abgeben
ich glaube verbote sind der falsche weg
ich glaube die richtigen maßnahmen die
leuchttürme die dazu führen dass leute
mut haben für die kommenden monate
das würde die mitte wieder beruhigen das
heißt die programme die auf gesetzt
werden müssen den leuten helfen jetzt am
rande ihrer existenz stellen